abbiamo incontrato con l'intervento di
un attimo fa la magia nel territorio
dove vi conduco io purtroppo non c'è la
magia non c'è la bacchetta magica
se ci fosse sarebbe bellissimo
sarebbe bellissimo poter fare in modo
che delle cose accadute non siano
accadute perché io mi occupo di
giustizia di giustizia penale
insegno diritto penale in università
cattolica dove lavoro nel centro studi
sulla giustizia penale e la politica
criminale e la vita mi ha dato
l'avventura di incontrare autori e
vittime di reato in contesti molto
particolari di cui mi piacerebbe
parlarvi
ma per farlo ho bisogno qualche minuto
di riflessione su che qual è il modello
di giustizia dominante ancora oggi il
diritto penale e sistemi di giustizia
penale
nascono per combattere la violenza ma di
fatto da millenni hanno utilizzato la
violenza per fare giustizia
anzi hanno reso la violenza giustizia il
modo più antico di fare giustizia è
proprio quello della ritorsione del male
del fare del male a chi ha fatto del
male e di chiamare questo male
raddoppiato questo raddoppio del male
giustizia è un'idea così antica così
comune che probabilmente ci sembra
normale anzi forse ci sembra convincente
e forse anche voi qui adesso state
dicendo beh sì certo che cosa bisogna
fare
nei confronti di chi ha fatto del male
se non restituirglielo il punto è che
una giustizia che smette di essere una
virtù e diventa l'esercizio di una
violenza anche se legittima è una
giustizia che pone tantissimi problemi
non so se ci avete mai pensato intanto è
una giustizia che assomiglia proprio a
quello che vuole combattere
emblematico il caso della pena di morte
dove per dire che non bisogna uccidere
lo stato uccide e uccide dicendo che
quella uccisione è giusta e la giustizia
e qui c'è un corto circuito evidente
un altro aspetto non so se ci avete di
nuovo pensato è che una giustizia che
coincide con la ritorsione del male è
una giustizia reo centrica per fare
giustizia occorre applicare una pena e
se non c'è qualcuno da punire
sembra che non ci sia giustizia da fare
per le vittime di reati che restano a
carico di ignoti o per le vittime dei
reati i cui autori muoiono
c'è molto da fare anche se non c'è
nessuno da punire ancora una giustizia
che coincide con il fare del male a chi
ha fatto del male è una giustizia nemica
della verità e della responsabilità
tanto è vero che in tutti gli
ordinamenti giuridici democratici esiste
il diritto costituzionale di difendersi
dalla giustizia e il diritto di difesa
che e un diritto inviolabile e
irrinunciabile che porta con sé anche il
diritto al silenzio da parte
dell'accusato e addirittura il diritto
al mendacio alla menzogna da parte
dell'accusato
abbiamo visto tutti i film polizieschi e
giudiziarie americane la scena
dell'arresto in cui il poliziotto
arresta al malvivente e cosa gli dice
hai diritto di rimanere in silenzio ma
se parli quello che dirai verrà usato
contro di te contro di te
un ultimo profilo una giustizia che
coincide con il fare del male a chi ha
fatto del male con il raddoppio del male
una giustizia mimetica rispetto al reato
è una giustizia eticamente pesante per
le vittime alle quali non resta per
chiedere giustizia che chiedere che un
nuovo male venga inflitto dopo quello
che loro hanno subito e ci sono delle
vittime che non sopportano questo cocus
tumorale e che infatti non vogliono
chiedere questa forma di giustizia
allora ci potremmo domandare se esiste
un altro modo di intendere la giustizia
è una domanda alla quale certo non posso
rispondere qui io adesso è da millenni
che gli uomini cercano la giustizia da
tempi immemorabili
c'è chi ha detto che nessuno sa cos'è la
giustizia ma tutti sappiamo molto presto
purtroppo cosa sono le ingiustizie
quelle le conosciamo bene
la risposta alla domanda è enorme
complessa possiamo dire subito che
certamente non basta un re
l'applicazione di una pena a risolvere
il problema della domanda di giustizia
occorrono delle politiche anti crimine
complesse articolate che partono dalla
scuola arrivano fino alle politiche
economiche e finanziarie
possiamo forse qui solo condividere una
brevissima riflessione su una modalità
nuova di intervenire dopo che un reato
purtroppo è già stato commesso perché
nel mondo
da alcuni decenni esiste questa idea
fragile timida di una giustizia mite che
si chiama giustizia riparativa e ne
parlano addirittura le nazioni unite che
la raccomandano e anzi premono per una
applicazione diffusa in tutti i paesi
del mondo
la definiscono così le nazioni unite la
giustizia riparativa qualsiasi
procedimento in cui la vittima è reo e
se opportuno altri membri della comunità
partecipano insieme attivamente a un
lavoro costruttivo sulle questioni
importanti nate dal reato partecipano
insieme attivamente per costruire sono
delle parole così lontane dalle manette
dalle sbarre dalle gabbie dai blindi dai
ferri dai braccialetti elettronici
dai vigilanti armati e sono delle parole
così vicine invece agli ideali di una
democrazia partecipare insieme
attivamente per costruire
nonostante il reato è una proposta
scandalosa
certamente perché la proposta di stare
insieme nel luogo tradizionale della
separazione della separazione del
carcere della gabbia dove si sta in
cattività è una proposta scandalosa
perché significa attivarsi e partecipare
nel regno incontrastato della passività
non esiste nessun luogo al mondo più
infantili zante di un carcere luogo in
cui le persone anche se adulte ancora
responsabili non possono decidere
nemmeno a che ora si va a dormire quando
si fa la doccia è una proposta
scandalosa perché chiede di impegnarsi
in modo attivo appunto laddove invece di
solito si subisce passivamente un male
sterile è una proposta che però molte
persone nel mondo
accettano e percorrono quest'itinerario
strano di incontro con il proprio altro
difficile in italia manca una legge
ancora sulla giustizia riparativa
ma questi percorsi sono praticati in via
sperimentale in ambito minorile anche
con gli adulti il ministero della
giustizia a un osservatorio sulla
giustizia riparativa e io la fortuna
appunto di aver
ha avuto l'opportunità di diventare
mediatrice penale ed incontrare autori
di reato e vittime in questi contesti di
confronto dialogico
conosco persone offese che mi dicono che
hanno incontrato la giustizia
solo grazie a questo strumento che i
processi penali le condanne al carcere
al colpevole non hanno dato loro
giustizia
conosco autori di reato che mi dicono
che hanno capito veramente che cosa
hanno fatto solo grazie all'incontro con
le vittime
conosco persone familiari di persone
uccise che ricevono il primo pensiero il
ricordo del ucciso nel giorno
dell'anniversario proprio dal loro
assassino che hanno incontrato in un
contesto di giustizia riparativa
c'è un paese il sudafrica che
addirittura ha scelto di rispondere con
un programma di giustizia riparativa
niente meno che al crimine di apartheid
al crimine della divisione per
eccellenza con la lungimiranza profetica
di figure come nelson mandela e desmond
tutu si è capito che se il sudafrica
post apartheid avesse utilizzato la
giustizia della bilancia della spalla
cioè la giustizia mimetica al reato la
giustizia della divisione della
separazione per rispondere al crimine a
parte ed il sudafrica non sarebbe mai
stato un paese dove potesse convivere un
popolo unito anche se multicolore e il
sudafrica nel 94 ha istituito la
commissione verità e riconciliazione
la commissione dove il modello di
giustizia portato avanti è stato quello
del dire la verità davanti alle vittime
alle comunità le quali rinunciavano nel
nome della verità
ad applicare una pena è una giustizia
scandalosa rivoluzionaria è una
giustizia che guarda al futuro che non
si ferma sul fotogramma congelato del
momento del reato ma guarda al futuro
delle relazioni è una giustizia degli
impegni dell'impegno attivo nel domani
senza dimenticare anzi facendo memoria
dell'oggi e infatti a me piacerebbe
molto e un po il mio sogno è il sogno di
altri che con me condividono la passione
per questa idea scandalosa eppure così
realistico e convincente di giustizia
penale che si passi da questa antica
immagine quasi universale della bilancia
che soppesa ma dove conti non tornano
mai e della spada che divide a un'altra
giustizia che guarda caso qui
rappresentata dal logo della corte
costituzionale sudafricana l'albero la
giustizia sotto l'albero sia si chiama
l'opera d'arte da cui è stato tratto il
logo della corte costituzionale del
sudafrica simbolo di una giustizia che
non serve per punire ma che serve per
proteggere e che serve per promuovere la
convivenza tra diversi la convivenza tra
quelle persone che sembrano così
impossibili così incapaci
impossibilitati a stare insieme quali un
re una vittima è una giustizia che non
dovete immaginare i re mistica buonisti
che gli incontri di giustizia riparativa
sono degli incontri forti a tratti sono
degli incontri violenti e noi mediatori
dobbiamo essere capaci di trasformare la
violenza il grido della domanda di
giustizia
in una parola ascoltabile dall'altro
difficile
una parola che si trasformi i
significati in valori che possono essere
toccati richiamati invocati per le
vittime fondamentale
che il reo riconosca che quello che è
accaduto non avrebbe dovuto succedere è
che ci sia un impegno affinché non
accada ad altri è una giustizia della
narrazione infatti noi lavoriamo tanto
sull'intreccio tra giustizia e
letteratura è una giustizia degli
impegni e della giustizia del sogno di
trasformare un fotogramma fermo bloccato
in un film in cui la storia viene messa
di nuovo in gioco in cammino
grazie